[Música]
vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta Moya y abrimos haciendo un repaso
por las portadas de la prensa británica
después del histórico acuerdo alcanzado
ayer entre el Primer Ministro y la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
Van Der Legend Y con esa entrada Marta
de los buenos días para usted Y qué
dicen estas portadas Buenos días Ángela
hemos destacado cinco portadas de los
periódicos británicos y no irlandeses
que retratan un poco pues lo que fue
ayer no ese histórico acuerdo entre
sunat y bonder Legend destacamos primero
la portada del independent hay como una
especie de
fotos similar en todas las portadas con
ese estrechamiento de manos entre ambos
líderes el independen titula miren quien
finalmente consiguió el brexit y no fue
usted Boris haciendo un poco gala de esa
ironía después de que el anterior
exprimir No consiguiera pues firmar ese
acuerdo que firmó ayer sunak destacamos
también el belfas telegraph que es un
periódico de referencia en Irlanda del
Norte que titula Maker break hacerlo o
frenarlo dice que los unionistas están
esperanzados con este acuerdo pero que
tendrán que evaluar si lo aceptan o no
sunak dijo ayer que los partidos
políticos tendrán que estudiar el
acuerdo y después se tendrá que votar en
El parlamento británico destacamos
también la portada del de Guardian que
titula el Primer Ministro aplaude esa
Nueva Era ese nuevo capítulo de las
relaciones con la Unión Europea y dice
que el acuerdo coreografiado Tuvo una
gran acogida pero que asuna todavía le
falta pues pasar esa Barrera de la línea
más dura de los brexitters destacamos
también la portada de metro que dice
1215 días después el acuerdo del brexit
Por fin se dio pueden encender el horno
esto En referencia Pues a que el proceso
todavía le queda bastante recorrido por
delante y por último destacamos el Daily
mail que decía que bueno destaca esa
foto entre el Rey Carlos III y bunder
Legend y además dice que Richie sunak se
pregunta ha conseguido lo imposible pues
mire igual esta es una noticia que está
en desarrollo Regina que estaba hoy en
belfast está haciendo promociones de
este acuerdo que logró vender leyen y
veremos si se puede convertir en una
realidad pero ahora le pido que vayamos
a Estados Unidos con una noticia bien
polémica el alto directivo de la cadena
Fox reconoció que los presentadores de
televisión de esta que es la cadena de
televisión más vista del país mintieron
y deliberadamente sobre las teorías de
fraude para mantener la audiencia en los
días posteriores a las elecciones
presidenciales del 2020 cuéntenos esta
historia así es hablamos de ruper marduk
que es el presidente ejecutivo de Fox
news que ayer admitió pues que algunos
de los presentadores y de las caras más
conocidas de la cadena mintieron eso
deliberadamente para mantener la
audiencia cuando en los días posteriores
a las elecciones presidenciales de
noviembre de ellos alentaban esas
teorías del fraude electoral porque el
Nicho de televidentes de la Fox news
está muy a la derecha y Bueno estaban a
favor de esas teorías del fraude
generalizado que también impulsaba el
expresidente Donald Trump las palabras
de mardoc vienen después de que la
empresa dominion System denunciara a la
Fox news por difamación acerca de Pues
cómo trataron esos resultados
electorales en los últimos días también
se ha hecho presente como los directivos
y esas caras del Canal decían una cosa
en público y otra en privado y también
destacamos un artículo de New York Times
que refleja precisamente eso no la
empresa dominion System consiguió
durante estos años miles de correos
electrónicos y además de mensajes
privados entre estos presentadores donde
Pues se ve perfectamente que en privado
decían pues que no había fraude
electoral y de que todo era como se
había estipulado en los resultados O sea
que Joe biden había ganado las
elecciones y sin embargo Pues en público
hacían pues sobrevolar ese fantasma
electoral se destaca en este artículo
del New York Times conversaciones entre
por ejemplo el productor Álex paper y
uno de los presentadores más conocidos
tuker carlson en los que decían que por
ejemplo el software Pues en privado
decían que no era fraudulento y en
público decían que sí o decían por
ejemplo que una de las ideólogas de las
teorías de la conspiración Sydney Powell
pues no tenía nada que ver con la
realidad y que era una loca y o sea en
público decían que era una estrella y
una gran estadounidense pues mire esto
Esto no parece tener fin no esta
historia del fraude electoral en Estados
Unidos y lo más grave Es que esto les
podría representar una multa Pero bueno
vamos a avanzar para terminar con un
artículo de la sección América futura
del país de España sobre un caso
impactante la justicia ecuatoriana lleva
a juicio a una empresa japonesa por
esclavitud moderna si Ángela hablamos de
la empresa furgawa plantaciones es una
firma japonesa que comercializa y
exporta el abacca que es esta variedad
del plátano con la que se fabrica el
papel moneda todo este caso no hace a
partir de 2018 cuando un informe de la
defensoría del pueblo relata que las
seis décadas en las que ha venido
operando esta empresa pues se han dado
condiciones de esclavitud moderna entre
los más de 1000 trabajadores de la
empresa pues trabajaban bajo condiciones
inhumanas de vivienda trabajo infantil y
Adolescente y ausencia absoluta de
derechos laborales por ello ayer la
jueza dijo que algunos de los dirigentes
de la empresa tendrán que sentarse en el
banquillo de los acusados para responder
a estas acusaciones y según la jueza las
víctimas tienen en común la
vulnerabilidad en su historia y la falta
de oportunidades laborales más de 100
empleados denunciaron a furukawa a esta
empresa y en estos momentos en paralelo
también hay otro proceso en el tribunal
constitucional para ver si el estado
tenía o no responsabilidad en todo este
caso pues es excepcional que se lleven
estos casos a juicio gracias a usted
Marta y nos vemos mañana Gracias